[Musique]
non
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
mode d'emploi vous aimez accueillir
conseiller servir ou bien encore créer
produire cuisiner alors aucun doute les
métiers de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration c'est fait pour vous mais
avant de passer à table je vous propose
un petit tour d'horizon sur les métiers
de la filière s'est tout de suite à
51,10 ville d'hôtellerie à la
restauration c'est 721 établissement un
secteur qui représente plus de 5000
emplois et 650 milles c'est le nombre de
chambres d'hôtel que compte la france
18300 d'établissement accueille les
touristes et si un quart d'entre eux
appartiennent à une chaîne il existe
toute une multitude de petits
établissements au charme discret mais
l'hôtellerie ce n'est pas seulement le
service en chambre
on y trouve des métiers aussi variés que
réceptionniste bagagistes barman des
métiers sans cesse aux compacts et au
service de la clientèle et de
l'hôtellerie et à la restauration il n'y
a qu'un pas celui qui nous emmène aux
cuisines chef de parti et cuisinier
commis ou bien encore sommelier les
laitiers difficile qui demande une
parfaite rigueur mais qui offre le
plaisir d'une grande créativité
en tout ce sont près de 50 filière qui
font de l'hôtellerie restauration
l'un des secteurs les plus recruteurs en
france les présentations sont faites
mais avant de se retrouver au lycée
hôtelier de guyancourt
un coup d'oeil sur le sommaire
aujourd'hui je vous emmène au cfaa
trajectoire de guyancourt 1 du ca fait à
la licence pro ce centre propose à
travers la voie de l'apprentissage les
formation très complète en hôtellerie et
restauration
nous partirons ensuite à la découverte
d'un petit hôtel de la région où le mot
service prend tout son sens chambres
raffinées chaleureuse belles tables et
cuisine de terroir
le tout en bordure de forêt de la vallée
de chevreuse petite escapade à l'auberge
du manet pour le plaisir des yeux et des
papilles et pour terminer grâce à la
famille mille voix nous mettrons les
petits plats dans les grands vous verrez
que la restauration ce n'est pas
seulement une question de contenance
vingt-quatre mille mètres carrés dédiés
à la formation ce sont les conditions
exceptionnelles que propose de cfa
trajectoire une dizaine de formations
préparent aux métiers de l'hôtellerie et
de la restauration
on voit ça tout de suite en images après
cinq ans de travaux c'est dans des
cuisines parfaitement équipés que des
élèves du cfa trajectoire peuvent se
former au métier de komi traiteur
cuisinier ou bien encore barman
on a des formations du ca paix jusqu'à
la licence professionnelle donc avec les
ca des classiques que l'on va retrouver
ses à la cuisine le service en salle
l'aspect pâtisserie et puis ensuite tout
ce que tous les bacs professionnels avec
le bac pro cuisine le bac pro
commercialisation et service en
restauration
et puis on est sur les filières
technologiques les bacs technologiques
donc là qu'ils ne peuvent pas se faire
en apprentissage uniquement sous statut
scolaire et ensuite on a toutes les
filières bts dut bts hôtellerie
restauration option a et b le bts ce
responsable hébergement et puis on a
toutes ces formations qui sont des
mentions complémentaires qui sont des
formations donnant que l'on peut faire
après avoir validé un diplôme de
l'enseignement professionnel comme la
mention complémentaire employés barmal
nansion complémentaire accueil réception
la mention complémentaire employé
traiteur et on a déposé un dossier pour
pouvoir ouvrir la marque sur
complémentaire sommellerie
une nouvelle section ouverte l'année
dernière permettent encore d'élargir les
formations aux apprentis en proposant
des classes de mise à niveau en
alternance c'est une filière qui permet
à des jeunes qui veulent se reconvertir
pour certains on fait un cursus
universitaire ou qui d'autre qui ont
peut-être mal choisi leur orientation de
pouvoir donc se réorienter vers
l'hôtellerie restauration donc sur le
cursus se fait en sur trois ans et ça
leur permet à la fin de pouvoir
décrocher leur examen donc
bts brevet technicien supérieur en
hôtellerie restauration après un bal
générale sandra a opté pour la filière
hôtellerie-restauration un choix qu'elle
ne regrette pas ça me passionne beaucoup
le fait de pouvoir puiser des aliments
de pouvoir créer mon propre dressage et
c'est vrai qu'au début j'étais un petit
peu c'est petit je me demandais ce que
ça va me réellement me faire pour mon
métier plus tard et c'est vrai que j'y
prends beaucoup de plaisir et je me lève
le matin en étant très contente d'aller
travailler donc c'est pourquoi d'abord
il ya beaucoup de relationnel
donc on se sent utile auprès du client
ensuite c'est vraiment un côté créatif
dont qui nous permet de nous découvrir
aussi de permettre de montrer nos
personnalités
donc on nous apprend beaucoup des
techniques de cuisine des techniques de
salle donc je suis principalement en
salle mais je fais aussi la cuisine à
l'école je suis en alternance nos deux
semaines en entreprise une semaine à
l'école et l'année prochaine j'aimerais
préparer mes besoins de bts toujours au
sein du cfa pour préparer l'option b
donc l'option pouvons au pouvoir
connaître encore plus de technique
malgré des horaires contraignants des
week-ends et vacances décalées
les jeunes apprentis sont très impliqués
un secteur où la motivation est
primordiale et
au scoutisme ce que j'adorais servir les
gens et ça m'est venu je me suis proche
d'entrer pas mon métier et voir le
sourire sur les gens quand je les
servaient aux scooters confessa forme de
buffet normalement je me suis dit je
vous donner ça à mes clients et je vais
voir ça pour ma vie
alors les inconvénients dans ce métier
c'est surtout puisque et horaires c'est
très compliqué non pas dimanche n'ont
pas de vacances en même temps les autres
les week-ends et sont souvent décalées
d'un désavantage
ben moi je vois un prend principalement
de formation c'est qu'on est en
apprentissage
faisons nous allions que théorique et
pratique ce qui nous permet justement de
performer dans ce domaine qui est
vraiment un métier manuel
et pourtant malgré la diversité des
métiers et une représentation féminine
importante
la pénurie en personnel est une vraie
réalité c'est un secteur qui a beaucoup
de mal à recruter parce qu'en fait c'est
vrai que nos brèves être technicien
supérieur en fait la plupart du temps
poursuivre leurs études en licence et
même parfois au delà et du coup vaut
s'orienter vers des métiers
comment dirais-je un petit peu plus
dedans cadron de manager donc parfois il
quitte le milieu de la cuisine où il
quitte le milieu de la restauration un
jeune qui rentre dans la filière
hôtellerie-restauration s'il est
passionné par son métier la cuisine par
exemple il continuera il y arrivera et
normalement il se fait un nom si
vraiment il est acharnée dans son
travail et rigoureux
des grands noms de la cuisine et des
parcours différents il y en a
aujourd'hui de paul bocuse à guy savoy
en passant par anne sophie pic ou bien
encore guy martin ils sont nombreux à
avoir développé nos palais à la grande
cuisine celle du terroir que la
réputation d'une petite auberge de
charme
ici à montigny le bretonneux et pour
cause elle est titrée maître
restaurateur
histoire d'un chef est également
création d'un hôtel restaurant bienvenue
à l'auberge du malaise créé par monsieur
bianchi il ya 25 ans l'auberge du man
est un petit établissement qui a su
trouver sa place dans un cadre verdoyant
mais avant d'en arriver là il a fallu
beaucoup de travail malin bianchi
responsable de l'auberge investi
énormément et la création d'un hôtel
restaurant n'est pas qu'une question de
passion à peu près 3 04 euros
pour ce faire l'opérateur pour faire une
surcouche in d'enfer pour pouvoir vivre
correctement
quand on a décidé donc de faire
l'extension c'est à dire faire 14
chambres supplémentaires on a emprunté
un million d'euros à la base pour faire
4 chambres qu'on a emprunté quasiment
à 100% sur les banques pour pouvoir les
empreintes et bien sûr on avait une
bonne renommée bien sûr on avait des
bons bilans bien sûr on avait un bon
compte d'exploitation
parce que sinon dans tous les cas de
figure on n'aurait jamais pu emprunter
cet argent au début pour pouvoir
démarrer je pense qu'il faut vraiment
avoir un peu d'argent pour un jeune
c'est petites structures ont peu de
moyens en bonne en plasma un bon produit
il ya beaucoup de choses qui rentrent en
compte c'est pas juste géants vont de la
petite entreprise en plus aujourd'hui
vingt-et-une personnes dont trois
apprentis parmi ces jeunes dans l'espoir
d'un emploi hier au east agir en salle
et passe une spécialisation barman
florian est réceptionniste en
apprentissage et terminera ses études en
août avec il l'espère une embauche à la
clé
quant à pierre il est en mise à niveau
pour passer le crp cuisine mais pour
madame bianchi le recrutement est
parfois un vrai parcours du combattant
pour le poste difficile si on veut avoir
quelqu'un de bien on fait une mauvaise
femme de ménage
il faudra du mauvais travail vous aurez
une nouvelle réputation
mon cuisinier et si l'auberge quatre
étoiles est aujourd'hui labellisé maître
restaurateur
c'est aussi grâce à son personnel
qualifié en cuisine le poisson n'a pas
de secret pour le chef de parti florian
qui ne maîtrisent parfaitement
[Musique]
thomas et le pâtissier de l'auberge
ils fabriquent également le pas maison
et pour encadrer cette équipe le chef
cuisinier rémy s'inspire de la provence
après un ca fait un bep en apprentissage
il a parcouru la france avant de se
fixer à l'auberge du manet
pour lui ce travail est pas un jeu de
hasard bagages et expériences font toute
la différence
j'ai commencé à 15 ans et demi à
travailler donc l'âge avoir une
trentaine d'années donc ça fait 15 ans
que je travaille ça va faire déjà 4 ans
juge-t-il que j'ai une place de second
donc j'ai fait beaucoup de maisons avant
tout pour me former pour avoir des bases
solides pour pouvoir prétendre après à
pouvoir gérer des personnes autour de
nous un grand avantage de notre métier
c'est de pouvoir partager ce que l'on
fait avec notre personnel
ainsi on peut le faire partager notre
clientèle qui est très important de
partager notre amour de la cuisine à la
clientèle pour faire une bonne cuisine
vous l'avez vu seuls les ingrédients ça
ne suffit pas il faut surtout un bon
cuisinier et du savoir faire
la famille mille voix nous fait partager
sa recette voyez plutôt de retrouver la
famille mille voix à chacun son métier
avec l'artisanat
quel beau mariage c'est peut être qu'on
n'a pas pu y aller
la robe de cattier les magnifiques les
petits fours ils sont pas d'angle quelle
variété
ça c'est la classe premium était obsédé
par la bouffe qu elle pas du tout
j'adorerais de grands traiteurs
j'organiserai des buffets sublime pour
les soirées de l'ambassadeur attend le
quotidien j'ai très peur c'est pas que
l'ambassadeur mais je sais mais le
quotidien sert à préparer l'exceptionnel
on perfectionne son art on cherche les
meilleurs fournisseurs de nouvelles
recettes et jour j voilà c'est exploser
son talent à la face du monde d'accord
mais aussi gagner d'argent plus pour
dépenser si tu vois ce que je veux dire
papa tu me fais confiance ou pas bah oui
alors ok en tout cas vu le nombre
d'enfants qu'on a à marier je pense
qu'elle va pouvoir tourner la boutique
avec choisir l'artisanat préfère vous
êtes désormais armé de tous les conseils
pour vous préparer aux métiers de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration
maintenant c'est à vous de jouer quant à
nous on se retrouve le 27 avril prochain
pour un nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi
consacré cette fois ci à la formation
professionnelle des adultes mais d'ici
là préparez vous de bons petits plats et
surtout prenez soin nouveau
[Musique]
à